charles blow new york times columnist
wrote a piece a few days ago defending
the cancellation of dr
seuss and adding a few more
um a few more people to to cancel to the
burn pile
or not really people actually he's now
we're going to cartoons we've done dr
seuss
canceling dr seuss books um and now and
we've already done
the muppets okay so they're canceled
they're but they're puppets
so we've gone from there and now we're
going all the way to the cartoon
characters he also called for the
cancellation of
speedy gonzalez and pepe le pew both of
looney tunes fame now
um it's been an interesting reaction to
both of these things
because he mentioned that speed speedy
gonzales is is insulting because it's a
it's a you know hispanic stereotype
and now there have been a lot of uh
latino people coming out
you know including celebrities um
gabriel iglesias who's the hispanic
comedian he's going to be voicing speed
gonzales in the new space jam
and he came out and they said we we love
speedy gonzales
which what yeah why why would if you're
up if you're a hispanic child
growing up especially back when looney
tunes was more popular
why wouldn't you love speedy gonzalez
he's the hero he's one of the good guys
right if i remember my
looney tunes mythology if i'm getting it
correct then then he's
always one of the good guys speeding as
alice is
so what's the problem exactly
you can say oh it's a stereotype it's a
caricature well it's a cartoon
of course it's both of those things
yosemite sam is a caricature elmer fudd
is a caricature
but isn't it also representation isn't
it isn't that what we
want see the left can never make up its
mind are we doing
are we getting rid of
all of these representations of minority
characters and minority culture are we
getting rid of all that stuff
or should we have more of it which is it
it can't really be both
so speeding as isles would seem to be
representation you would think it'd be
the kind of thing that the left would
celebrate but we were told we have to
cancel them
and also pepe le pew um
who uh charles blow argue argues
uh normalizes rape culture
because as you remember if you if you
can think back to watching looney tunes
pepe le pew
um you know uh a rather
a a a a skunk who
you know has voracious sexual appetites
um and is always pursuing in particular
i think it was a black and white cat
that he always
that always confuses with a skunk and
he's always pursuing this this female
cat
but the thing is he always loses she
always gets away
and he's not the good guy we're not
supposed to empathize
the message in looney tunes isn't that
we should empathize with uh with
with popular people he's absurd it's
ridiculous the kids watch that
and they think it's ridiculous they
laugh at it
which is a good message now the main
message because it's a cartoon it's
looney tunes the main message is this is
all silly and ridiculous
and don't take it too seriously but if
you are going to take it seriously
then the real then if you're looking for
a more serious message
then the message you would take is that
his behavior is bad
don't act like that which is why i could
be wrong
but uh in spite of charles blows claims
you know i i don't think it's it's very
often that you hear of sex offenders who
cite pepe le pew
as one of their primary influences could
be wrong i haven't really i haven't
looked into this haven't researched it
but i'm guessing that if i did you're
gonna very rarely find a real-life
rapist or sex offender
who says that he got into this uh into
this life because he watched a lot of
pepe le pew cartoons as a child
and by the way if we're finding a reason
for pepe le pew to be offensive
shouldn't it be that he that he's a that
he's a stereotype
of the french isn't if it's a
if he's offensive for any reason isn't
that it
he's a french rapist skunk
isn't that offensive to if it's
offensive to anyone
wouldn't it be offensive to french
people
speedy gonzalez is a is a is a
a hero you know he's one of the
protagonist characters
pebble pew is a bad guy basically
um a rapist or attempted
a skunk and he's french
but no see that can't be offensive
because
french people are white stereotypically
they're white so so that that's that's
okay
we got to find another reason for pepe
to be offensive and this is it
um and it doesn't stop there so we're we
are now
officially uh doing a me too
with pepe le pew pebble pew is getting
me tood a cartoon character
you thought they would stop at people
but no no now we're going to cartoon
characters
and the hollywood reporter has this it
says the controversial looney tunes
skunk cartoon
character popular pew was scrubbed from
the lebron james
um the new lebron james space jams space
space gym
space jam 2 is coming out we just
mentioned uh speedy gonzales is good
still is going to be in space jump 2 as
far as we know but pepe le pew has been
removed
from space gm2 now they claimed that
this decision was made
a year ago so not directly in response
to this new york times piece
that's what they claim anyway but one
way or another he's being taken out
presumably because he normalizes rape
culture and
he's offends and not because he's
offensive to french people
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content